alors sur l'attitude adoptée vis-à-vis
du Front national les voix du Front
national les commentairire de nos deux
invités mie on fait court puisque vous
intervenez à deux reprises dans cette
édition on commence par Monsieur ségin
puisque c'était vous qui étaz concerné
avec le camp de Monsieur Chirac on a le
sentiment que Monsieur Chirac s'adresse
directement aux électeurs du Front
national et à eux seuls en leur disant à
peu près je résume je vous ai compris et
croyez-vous que Monsieur Le Pen va se
laisser ainsi contourner d'abord un mot
remercier Jean-Pierre cheven de bien
vouloir accepter de participer avec moi
à des jeux de cirque puisque c'est ainsi
que Monsieur mitan appelle des
rencontres des débats entre hommes
public alors pour répondre pour répondre
très précisément à votre question je
dirais ceci il ne faut pas renoncer à
l'idéal qui nous anime mais cependant
regarder autour de soi ouvrir les bras
tendre la main
comprendre ce que veulent les autres
faire un pas supplémentaire et le 8 mai
nous gagnerons monsieur Chevenement vous
êtes député maire de Belfort or dans
votre ville le Front national obtient
presque 18 % des voix 1775 il n'y a donc
pas que la droite qui est concernée par
ce phénomène vous aussi à gauche vous
avez besoin des voix de Monsieur Le Pen
pour gagner il y a eu beaucoup de
suppression d'emploi dans la région de
BELFOR Montbelliard chez peugugot Alstom
Bull et naturellement il y a des
problèmes qui se posent j'ajoute que les
voix qui sont portées sur le front
national viennent souvent de la droite
et Monsieur Chirac paye le prix de la
banalisation du racisme et de la
banalisation du Front national je
rappelle que en franchecté il y a 10
jours tous les membres de la majorité
ont voté pour un vice-président délégué
du Front national de même que le Front
National a voté pour pour un président
qui n'est personne d'autre d'ailleurs
que le suppléant d'un ministre RPR un
collègue de Monsieur segin monsieur
Bergelin donc il y a cette banalisation
qui est grave et je pense que les
électeurs sont assez grands pour savoir
où sont leurs intérêts et ils savent en
particulier dans ma région que leurs
intérêts ne coïncident pas avec ceux de
Monsieur Chirac dont le premier geste a
été par exemple de supprimer l'impôt sur
les grandes fortunes la question de
Patricia était que ferez-vous des voix
du Front national si elle se pte sur
votre candidatz pas vous avez
l'équilibre droite gauche dans ma région
et dans ma ville n'a pas été modifié par
cette élection hein c'est surtout sur
monsieur Chirac que Jean-Marie Le Pen a
pris ses voix comme d'ailleurs au niveau
national est-ce que vous estimez tous
les deux qu'il y a une responsabilité
politique à droite comme à gauche du
score actuel du Front national ou est-ce
que c'est quelque chose de plus profond
disons sociologique il y a une
responsabilité politique ceux qui ont
passé des alliances avec le Front
national dans six conseils régionaux
dans plusieurs municipalités qui par
exemple ont voulu mettre en œuvre le
code de la nationalité la réforme du
Code de la nationalité dont on s'est
aperçu les meilleurs esprits même
quelquefois des hommes de droite comme
Monsieur Chaunu que ça ne tenait pas de
bout ils sont revenus en arrière alors
il me semble que quand on flatte cette
fibre euh raciste et bien à la fin on
récolte ce qu'on a semé j'espère je pour
Chun monsieur alors sur la
responsabiloui j'allis vous le dire sur
la responsabilité de la montée du Front
national bien écoutez ce que j'observe
avec beaucoup d'intérêt à la réponse de
Monsieur
chevenenem c'est que finalement les voix
de Monsieur Le Pen sont visiblement
impures lorsqu'elle risque de se porter
sur monsieur Chirac mais que par une
savante alchimie dont je n'arrive pas à
trouver le secret elle se purifie dès
lors qu'elles vont chez Monsieur
mitteran tant mieux pour lui d'ailleurs
qu'il y ait cette purification parce que
comme vous l'indiquiez un instant des
voix de Monsieur Le Pen monsieur
mitteran pour être élu en aurait besoin
et je ne vois pas pourquoi on concentre
on polarise le débat quant au destin de
ces voix sur le sol candidat Chirak il
n'y a pas de voix impure mais il y a des
idées impur mais il y a des ID avec
lesquel vous avez c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur chevenem votre
candidat mais peut-être n'était-ce pas
avec votre appui a souhaité grâce à la
représentation proportionnelle donner ce
coup de pousce positif décisif à
Monsieur Le Pen qui nous vaut les
chifres auourdhui besoin de cela pour
exister je vous le dis la seule façon de
s'opposer dès lors que vous considérez
que c'est danger ux à la montée du
phénomène Le Pen c'est le vote pour
Monsieur Chirac avec Monsieur mitteran
élu je vous le dis et vous vous en
souviendrez ce sera dans 6 mois dans un
an Monsieur Le Pen entre 20 et 25 %.
alors je ne fais pas confiance à
Monsieur Chirac qui comprend le racisme
pour combattre Jean-Marie Le Pen s'il
était gooliste il se souviendrait de ce
mot de malerau commencer à comprendre
c'est se refuser à juger monsieur
chevement vous vous souvenez de la
phrase que j'ai prononcé tout à l'heure
il faut regarder autour de soi ouvrir
les bras tendre la main comprendre je
reprends le verbe ce que veulent les
autres une phrase c'est une phrase de
Monsieur mitéran de Monsieur mitteran
hier à
pointapitre comme le démontre comme le
démontre la dépêche que j'ai iciieur
vous restez en notre compagnie il faut
comprendre que nous devons continuer ce
journal et dérouler
l'actualité cite franç c'est très
bien monsieur c'est moins souvent et
voilà on s'arrête le candidat écologiste
Antoine wchter ne donne pas de consigne
de vote lui pour le second tour mais
soumet cinq propositions aux deux
candidats qui restent face à face alors
il dit ce sont cinq priorités sur
lesquelles il attend des réponses et son
score je vous le rappelle n'est pas
négligeable un peu moins de 4 % des
suffrages reportage Pascal
deschan en demandant beaucoup on est sûr
d'obtenir un peu c'est sans doute la
raison pour laquelle ce matin Antoine
westter s'est montré c'est exigeant jugé
plutôt il réclame l'instauration du
référendum d'initiative populaire
l'abandon définitif du surgénérateur de
crémalville et l'arrêt de la
construction de toute nouvelle centrale
nucléairire la mise en place d'un
véritable ministère de l'Environnement
l'arrêt des essais nucléaires de Mururoa
et des ventes d'armes aux pays en guerre
et enfin la mise en place d'un revenu
social garanti désormais la balle est
dans le camp des deux candidats bien ce
que j'attends des deux candidats c'est
qu'en réalité il se détermine par
rapport librement par rapport finalement
à ces points mais qu'il se détermine
directement face
euh à l'électorat car encore une fois je
ne donnerai aucune consigne de vote ce
sont finalement mes électrices et mes
électeurs de choisir la meilleure
attitude possible au second tour et une
attitude qui comporte une vaste gamme de
possibilités nous allons maintenant tout
de suite à la Bourse hier vous vous
souvenez elle avait accusé le coup du
du premier tour et puis là apparemment
Jean Lebert ça remonte alors les
boursiers ça va ça vient expliqueznous
cela oui William aujourd'hui on fait de
la bourse au palais et pas de politique
et c'est de la hausse après la déception
d'hier les boursiers font preuve de
réalisme aujourd'hui ils réalisent qu'il
ne peut y avoir de grands changements
dans la politique économique de la
France quel que soit le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle 1992 est
proche et la politique économique de la
France ne veut pas être très éloigné de
la politique communautaire résultat
l'indicateur de tendance monte de 1,62
%. et les boursiers s'intéressent à
nouveau au très bons résultats des
sociétés françaises comme Peugeot
Michelin ou encore Somer liber dont les
résultats progressent de plus de 50 %.
sur notre tableau des plus fortes
variations à la hausse fiveling gagne
plus de 10 % navigation mixte au plus
haut de l'année gagne 8,8 %. sat à 804
francs gagne 8,8 % don satat dont Matra
vient de prendre le contrôle de 15 % du
capital et Matra au plus haut de l'année
à 160 francs qui gagne 5,2 %. avec Matra
enchaîne sur les privatisés elle aussi
bien orienté Paris bas gagne 9 francs
saint-gobin 5 francs CGE 2 francs suè
gagne 8 francs le CCF est un changer sur
le marché des devises le dollar a
légèrement reculé à 5 Fran 68 de même
que la livre sterling à 10 fran67 le
dutchm est stable à 3 franc 3960 le
franc français est ferme ce matin et
l'écu est à 7 Frans 05 sur le marché de
l'or on a reculé à Paris - 550 francs
par kilo à 81700 et 2 francs de baisse à
510 francs sur le Napoléon voilà will on
a regagné aujourd'hui ce que l'on avait
perdu hier il faut dire que les
boursiers se sont consacrés un peu plus
à leur travail et ont discuté un peu
moins politique merci Jean ben nous nous
discuterons politique dans un instant ce
journal n'est pas terminé puisque nous
allons parler du chômage alors
précisément les chiffres du chômage ont
été publiés hier ils font apparaître une
amélioration sensible avec la baisse de
1,8 % du nombre des demandeurs d'emploi
le mois dernier ce qui fait sur un an
une baisse de 4,7 % chiffre contestés
immédiatement par Michel dobar ancien
ministre socialiste du travail en effet
estime lui que cette baisse n'est pas
crédible nous allons en reparler bien
sûr avec nos invités mais tout d'abord
les chiffres avec F mé il y avait donc
46800 personnes de moins inscrites sur
les listes de la NPE à la fin du mois de
mars qu'à la fin du mois de février
première explication le boom des stages
en tout genre TUC sivvp formation en
alternance 80000 demandeurs d'emploi
sont entrés en stage au mois de mars
presque deux fois plus qu'il y a 1 an
deuxème explication les radiations des
listes par les services de la NPE ont
été bon in près de 70000 personnes soit
11000 de plus que le mois précédent ont
été rayé des statistiques pour cause de
refus d'emploi ou de formation ou d'une
non réponse à une convocation troisème
explication une reprise réelle de
l'activité économique au mois de mars
que confirme les enquêtes de l'INC et
les recettes en hausse de la sécurité
sociale enfin une panne d'ordinateur a
décalé 10000 radiations de février sur
Mars au total le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi a baissé de 130000 depuis 1 an
mais il est en hausse de 70000 par
rapport à mars
1986 alors nous retrouvons nos deux
invités monsieur ségin Chevénement pour
un commentaire sur les chiffres du
chômage et puis vous nous direz
messieurs pour terminer les les trois
raisons pour lesquelles il faut voter au
second tour pour votre candidat alors
commençons par le chômage Gilles ou en
dehors des chiffres et de la de la
contestation de ces chiffres est-ce que
vraiment il y a deux politiques
différentes qui puissent être nommé qui
puissent être élaboré après le 8 mai
entre la gauche et la droite quêre
différences pour les électeurs je pense
pas il y a qu'une politique possible je
crois que monsieur chevedem est bien
placé pour avoir apprécier en qualité de
ministre de l'Industrie en qualité de
ministre de l'éducation
nationale deux choses la première c'est
que compte tenu de l'évolution
technologique qui affecte l'industrie à
titre principal accessoirement les
services le nombre de postees n'exigeant
aucune qualification se réduit comme pot
de
chagrin deuxièmement nous avons un
énorme effort de formation à faire et je
dirais volontiers que la crise que nous
ressentons souvent comme une crise
quantitative et peut-être aussi et
peut-être surtout une crise qualitative
le corps social a quelques difficulté à
répondre par la formation notamment à la
rapidité de l'évolution technologique et
à ses
conséquenceatria oui messieur ne pensv
oui d'avoir la réponse de Monsieur chev
oui moi je ne pense pas que il n'y ait
qu'une politique possible dans le
domaine de l'éducation nationale ou en
matière de politique industrielle il y a
deux politiques différente cela dit le
problème est un problème très difficile
nous avons parlé tout à l'heure du score
de Le Pen mais 2 millions et demi de
chômeurs qui pensait que la France
pourrait le supporter et est-ce que
d'une certaine manière ce n'est pas là
l'humus sur lequel prospère le virus du
Front national donc il faut s'interroger
aussi sur le fait de savoir si on peut
considérer toujours le chômage comme un
résidu comme un solde d'une politique
destinée par exemple à lutter contre
l'inflation et ça pose le problème à mon
avis d'une initiative européenne de
croissance on ne peut pas accepter que
l'Europe soit une zone de déflation par
rapport à à aux États-Unis ou au Japon
qui ont contenu le chômage grâce à la
croissance et c'est donc l'Europe sur
laquelle il faut
peser pour que elle soit une zone de
croissance mieur dimanche dernier 30 %
des électeurs ont choisi Monsieur Le Pen
et ce qu'on appelle les petits partis
alors n'est-ce pas un avertissement pour
vous les grandes formations politiques
notamment sur ce problème du chômage un
constat que vous ne convainquez pas que
vos solutions ne convainquent pas au
moins 30 % du corps électoral il est
bien possible que le discours passe mal
c'est c'est même difficilement
contestable encore que Monsieur
chevenenem en tant que voisin comme moi
de l'Alsace pourrait dire qu'on a
assisté dans cette région et en Mosel
accesso
mais surtout en Alsace à une poussée du
Front national que ni un sentiment
particulier d'insécurité ni une
situation particulièrementve grave du
chômage parce que je pense que vous
souhaiteriez tout comme moi avoir les
taux de chômage de l'Alsace ne peut
expliquer donc il est probablement
d'autres raisons sans pour autant
contester celle qu'évoquait monsieur
chev oui je dis je dirais je suis
d'accord avec Philippe sin il y a un
rejet de de l'autre qui qui est à mon
avis quelque chose de
d'effrayant je crois que le mal ça
existe d'une certaine manière monsieur
voilà il nous reste à peu près un peu
plus de 2 minutes pour terminer cette ce
débat je vous demande de nous donner les
deux trois raisons maximum pour lesquels
il faut voter pour votre candidat
respectif et les trois mauvaises raisons
de voter pour le candidat adverse alors
monsieur segin avait commencé tout à
l'heure vous permettez que monsieur
chevement commence maintenant allez-y ma
réponse est simple pour faire face au
défi de la guerre économique mondiale au
défi que la France a devant elle au défi
de la démocratie qui ne marche pas si
bien il faut être capable de rassembler
et François mitiran est capable de
rassembler c'est ma première raison
deuxièmement pour rassembler il faut la
justice sociale je pense que la gauche
est porteuse d'un dessin de justice
sociale puis troisièmement je dirais
c'est par patriotisme je pense que la
France sera mieux représentée par
François mittiron qui est non seulement
un humaniste et un homme de caractère
mais qui donne de la France l'image dans
laquelle moi je me reconnais l'image de
la République de la France des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et et et
inversement je ne sens pas cela chez
Monsieur Chirac je pense que Monsieur
Chirac a été fait prisonnier par
Monsieur Le Pen au premier tour et que
s'il était élu ce serait une mauvaise
chose pour l'image de la France dans le
monde et une mauvaise chose pour les
Français Monsieur S très rapidement
aussi je suis au moins enfin d'accord
avec Jean-Pierre cheminem et ce qui n'a
peut-être pas dit aussi explicitement ce
que je vais dire à savoir que dans cette
élection et depuis des mois et des
années on parle beaucoup de l'Europe on
parle beaucoup de la décentralisation
des nouvelles collectivités et cetera on
n peut-être pas parlé assez de la France
et il faut en parler davantage alors
pour ce qui me concerne je choisis
jacirac parce que je pense qu'il est le
plus susceptible de rassembler parce que
c'est un homme dont je pense qu'il
réussira il en a apporté la preuve de
années durant et parce que je crois
qu'il incarne l'avenir et que ça n'est
pas le cas de son concurrent bien
monieur j'ai remarqué monsieur ségin
c'est Patricia qui me faisait remarquer
que ça fait à de repris vous dit je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur Je ça nous a un
peu il a fa dire aussi il l' dit au
moins une fois voil vous avez cité non
c'est pas ce cou vous pourriez
travailler ensemble vous pourriez
travailler ensemble
gouvernement quel serait le premier
ministre qui aurait cette idée làà bah
écoutez alors s' se présente problème
alors s'il se présente
l'avait bah écoutez pour l'instant ça lu
fait sourire merci Monsieur en tout cas
de de votre présence et d'avoir fait en
tout cas d'avoir respecté la règle du
jeu